[Music]
everyone simulation we have a very very
special guest with us today we have
Bernard goo inter hello thank you I
thank for having me thanks for inviting
me to San Francisco thank you in a while
all right thanks for coming Bernard man
where do we start
Ron Vargas first introduced me to your
work Ron's been how long have you been
with Ron's work now ah with Bernard
years I was looking for the information
that he speaks about and produced a film
about and I found piercing the veil of
reality and I just discovered it to be
the most comprehensive film on the are
we alone question that we so famously
ask on the show yeah and I've been
following him on Facebook ever since and
that's it's a the things that he talks
about it's just a long process to you
know comprehend and then to practice so
it's great to have among the show to
talk more about it and share with our
audience so nine years for Ron and then
he introduced me to you a couple months
ago and I fell in love with the work as
well very deep work piercing the veil of
reality has been 12 years no in the
making that's a really long amount of
time to be focusing on a lot of esoteric
subjects a lot of culture a lot of
matrix theory a lot of spirituality and
transcendence all these different
subject areas that you kind of tap into
human psychology so this is gonna be fun
Bernard geek give us give us the scoop
on your life so you were born in LA then
went to Germany for most of your life
and then came back yeah well actually a
lot of people don't know that I was
actually born in Los Angeles both my
parents are German
they lived in Los Angeles late 60s early
70s my dad made his PhD at UCLA and then
I was born
and my mom wanted to get a hell out of
there did for me to grow up in Los
Angeles god bless her
and they moved back with me when I was 1
year old and then you know I grew up in
Munich Germany really just going through
the program always felt you know was the
loner so to speak never really fitting
in and then I found music drums and
percussion actually when I was in a
University of Munich studying business
because I thought that's what I need to
do to become happy to make money and all
of that and through synchronicities its
grace I met my friend back then and I
started playing drums and had this
transcendental experience was just like
this is what I need to do what I want to
do for my life quit University saved up
money and moved to Los Angeles at the
age of 22 to go to music school to study
drums and just stayed there friends are
beautiful
oh yeah it's especially because I like
dancing it's like the perfect
combination between making music and you
know physically expressing yourself so
there was a you know and I was really
focused and almost this obsessed with
drums playing 4 to 6 hours a day and
nothing else and just you know looking
back and it was actually my spiritual
practice especially in terms of shadow
work because I was really into pretty
dark heavy music but it's fun to play it
on the drums right and that initiated
deeper processes and I'm you know
battling with my own emotional
sensitivity and depression so I
naturally started to ask questions and a
lot of people asked me how I got into
the work and I can summarize it in one
word is suffering right immediately
understand myself figure myself out
still couldn't fit in what's going on in
this planet you know starting to
question it and then when he asked the
question doors open and synchronicities
teachers mentors teachings books come
across tumble down the rabbit hole then
I found another gift bodywork of myself
healing work right went through that
initiation found yoga she gone you know
that's what I've started out more with
the inner work actually it's virtually
no work psychology young psychology and
then I delve deep into the rabbit hole
come basic conspiracy and then wanted
the fringe the UFO topic right aliens
also influenced how did you go from how
that right in GUI pause because of my
own experience especially psychedelics
and all back in the days I was really
when I you know when I get into
something I get into something so and
explored psychedelics quite and 10-30
back in the days that you know I was
part of the rave scene like we had these
illegal raves once a month you know out
in the desert somewhere and that's where
I was my introduction to basically in
this particular psilocybin mushrooms and
DMT already back in the late 90s early
2000 and you know one it really asked me
this question one big part was always
always felt that we're not alone you
know even I remember as a child like
being out in the fields in Germany
looking in the sky and like almost like
take me back home kind of thing but not
consciously realizing it so they always
felt there's something else and you know
when I had my more intense psychedelic
experience especially had those of
mushrooms
you know dove people talk about
spiritual experiences but for me it was
more like an alien experiences you know
kind of was confronted with these
entities and beings as other
intelligence and it felt so Elyan yet
familiar to me in a weird way well it so
that kind of was the trigger and then
books or you know certain material came
across and kind of dug myself through it
so to speak and do you feel you being
channelled I don't
yeah something something is coming
through you something is trying to
communicate all the information that you
talk about and write about do you feel
it's not necessarily from you but
through you that it's a
luhan's entity even though you are yeah
you have dealt tricky territory yes
exactly but I feel sometimes something
you know is channeling me coming through
me and it's not from me I sometimes say
wow where did this thought come from so
do you do you feel that you experience
the same way I definitely small more in
terms of like I collect even downloads
but even I write like for me we talked
about that briefly before the writing
process right it's very serious to me
like even I would be a horrible staff
writer I cannot write on command write
whatever you know I don't write many
essays or blogs maybe two or three a
year but it's like it's just coming down
and just reflect also my own life and I
get this information and I don't try to
overthink it you know then I do my
research and kind of like comment it
confirms it in many ways and I try to
structure it and put it into the
limitations of words and language you
know but I feel like it's no different
like any true artist in the sense I feel
a true artist also gets the inspiration
from somewhere else if not it's not him
or her doing it right I think we all tap
into that and in varying degrees right
so it's not you know we all kind of
channels on some level and then the
tricky part is like whatever we align
ourselves was because in the end I
realized if you were always just
transducers of higher energies it's not
really ask me doing and who is the ivic
that's a whole philosophical question
itself right but when you think about
the I the I was part it's just the
accumulation of memory and experiences
but who is this I and then it's
paradoxical and one part of me wants
this the other that what is the eye
without time so I feel there's this you
know line what I also call you know I'm
gonna look back into my life I felt you
know you can only kind of connect the
dots talking back and then I feel
there's always this force benevolent
divine force in the sense that pull the
push me in a certain path what I'm here
to do from a higher perspective right
and it's not up to me I've neither
control of it you know and as I said
many times I can summarize my life by
the saying to God your plans
evil laugh at you
anything I plan never really happened
I've thought I wanted well the things I
thought I wanted back in my 20s or 30s
did manifest and I'm glad I did invest
because the real estate was not coming
from our true selves anyway but meant
for my own conditioning wounds a lot of
people when we grow up in culture and
conditioning program and have desires
and wants and needs they're not even
their own but programmed into them right
and there's a soul calling for something
else and we can call it soul purpose or
what not right so it's about this
alignment getting yourself out of the
way
which is either said than done but
that's the whole part of a field of
esoteric work right they become a
conscious transducer fire energy is the
divine of whatever you may want to call
it let's stay on this for a little bit
so we have something channeling through
us our actualization what our value that
were supposed to bring to the world we
have to get we have to get the ego out
of the way of that tell us more well the
ego like the conditioned ego personality
which we mostly identify with right
which is not our true self and what is
the true so that's you know that's I
would say like okay words language right
our divine nature like soul and what is
that can you prove it right the Atheist
materialist will have a hard problem
with this so the divine nature the soul
that's the true self and then the ego is
not the true self yeah it's like you
know the just I have sometimes problem
people destroy your ego the ego is bad
it's not like that it's more like
fine-tuning or D conditioning and
yourself which is intense process to the
disillusionment and all this stuff comes
out we need to heal and bring the soul
the psyche being a shrew you better set
to the front like neh Eric teaching
talks about the necessity to like Girja
talks about to grow the soul that we
don't know how to have actually true
access to it and then add understanding
alright and then the ego person becomes
a pure expression of that because we
still did we all have a needy go to
exist in
3d reality ego becomes an expression of
soul of essence that's a essence right
and the but but more often it's
important for that divine nature to
shine the soul to shine than it is for
the ego mask to come on and shine so
then you can move between the soul and
then the ego as in needed what both then
it becomes an interface right it's like
it's not separated it's it's an
interface together the way I would
describe and then you you up you you
kind of up regulate one of the energies
as needed in yourself rather than living
in only the ego or rather than in living
and only the divine well the only the
divine is I most like what it feels
almost they escape when you just escaped
into some cave and then Malaya's and
just be in some audio no vana or you
know I mean that's you know and some
level I find that the exit spiritual
bypassing the extreme to escape the
world yes rather than anchoring the
divine force and year for a reason and
do our work and contribute
yeah and engage and not escape from life
that's the let's stay there again
contribution mm-hmm so a lot of our
meaning or our actualization comes from
contribution providing the world with
some value that we can then reflect back
on and see the tribe has said thank you
for this value that you have brought to
us in terms of service there right so to
speak and then we all have our unique so
potential like so it's so talent so
whatever purpose you want to call it
like including soul essence so the more
you tune deeper into that then you truly
as a connect to your vocation what are
you here to do contribute from a higher
level and it's so very unique to you and
only you can do and you're the best at
it so it really thank cancels out any
form of competition right or ambition or
any of that because it's your unique
contribution so to speak it's nothing
you learn at school or can get certified
in but they don't teach you that at
school oh that's the only all I'm sure
talk about the matrix further into the
button but that's a good point because
you know on the basic level in
educational educational system the
intellect is worship right the mind it's
about memorizing grading right you don't
know nothing about emotional
intelligence you're not being told about
the body-mind connection how to tune
into your intuition it's almost like
discouraged like your dream I don't
don't trust your feelings right so what
happens more more is the body mind
splitting it keeps us up in the head and
we mostly live out of their head then
right and the mind and I'm not
demonizing the mind it has its place
total right logical rational like it has
its place but if it's disconnected from
being from our connect disconnected from
our higher nature then the trouble kicks
in right and then we can be manipulated
by all kinds of forces as well because
we have lost the inner connection right
it's actually very the mind is great for
doing things we do right now to
translate and communicate right yeah but
it's the worst place to make decisions
from that's I've seen a lot of people
get themselves myself into trouble when
we make decisions from up here rather
than from our intuitive guidance that
deep and the guts right in the body
that's deep about it hmm mmm that you
know it's it's more than a feeling it's
a deeper knowing but for that we need to
be embodied get out of here you start to
trust ourselves let's stay on embodiment
now that's yeah because that's been a
pillar of your practice and if one of
your teachings okay so I wonder let's go
back in evolution a little bit and just
where where did this moment evolution
yeah thank you
where did where did okay well maybe we
should address that before we get to my
question then why evolution
what do you understand on the evolution
let's put it this way I'm talking about
the last couple million years of
evolution to transition from the
chimpanzee to the human didn't we talk
about this this morning though you just
gave me the same air quote but then we
didn't go into detail furthermore what
is your you're talking about the fish
evolution that we the official
scientific evolution
that we evolved from apes chimpanzees
yes and all of that correct through in
the missing link well I don't know like
I don't agree with it okay explain yes
right I mean for me there's has been I
mean it ties into many other things
right obviously official College of what
we've been told and taught history you
know if you dive deeper and and really
ask questions you tap into this whole
matrix you know which is also I talked
about the madest control system and then
everything what we've told and taught is
actually is it's a very distortion would
happen or lies and a lot of stuff has
been suppressed and left out even an
official story official history I mean
is in many ways like agreed upon what
about all of your archaeology you know
and there's not a mysterious but they're
sort of there's an excellent book I
forgot who wrote it but called hidden
archaeology there are things that have
been hidden away from official society
so to speak not to in order not to
disturb the oh you know or get people
upset or worried about you know the
evolution consensus anomalies okay
ancient civilizations that have been
already actually far more were far more
advanced than we are you know with this
evolutionary model and there's almost we
believe ourselves on the pinnacle of
evolution we are like everything whoever
was in the past was primitive because
they didn't have the kind of technology
right big
sure but even the advanced civilizations
prior to us are still within the realm
of a couple thousand ten thousand years
is that yeah hundred thousand okay so
now the follow-up question to that is if
not evolution in the way that we are
taught evolution then what is the
explanation for humans
well I based on my own revelations and
research or that part of it is that we
have been partially also interfered with
create quote-unquote created genetically
modified by alien forces entities in
whatever shape and for physically hyper
dimensionally
and kind of disconnected us from our
original genetic blueprint the fall from
Eden right the fall from our original
state which ironically better
paradoxically was also a free will
decision to experience this eagle
consciousness so to speak in this game
drama yeah comedy horror show we
experience right now to find our way
back home
three-ring circus so to speak you know
now the irony you see the the opposite
of this evolutionary darkness theory is
the religious dogmatic Christian you
know fundamental condition creationist
God made created the world in seven days
in the world is only what five thousand
years old that's the other extreme you
know they adore so but maybe it is like
something in-between neither right but
there's something else we haven't really
considered and that we may not be here
the main show on planet Earth uh-huh
okay so I think it's gonna be we need to
definitely put a flag in that one and
make sure we climb back up that mountain
of not being the main show on earth okay
let's come back just a little bit
when did the then transition occur were
we ever a very embodied species prior to
this disconnect and how long ago do you
think that was I mean the difference I
cannot give you like a definite answer
because a lot of it is also just I
prefer this theory so to speak even the
big night when you think about the
evolution also just a theory like Big
Bang is a theory even scientifically
spoken right but you know various
resource it's about between three or
five hundred thousand years ago and
linear time so to speak from various
sources and you know but what's
important to keep in mind that we are
still being interfered of and modified
in different ways which we see in this
day and age let's do it what time let's
climb well I may be gone was doing a dig
in the past but you know I just want to
say something yeah you know it's just my
to the past because people talk about
hope you know the ancient cultures the
pyramid cultures Egyptians or the you
know back even more inch in the marine
we can go into Atlantis which is a whole
mystery in itself right that there's no
evidence archaeologically but you know
we we have been so conditioned and
programmed especially this day and age
of the rise of technology we think we're
so advanced because we have all of these
gadgets you know I had but I would ask
more that this is actually a reaction or
expression of externalizing technology
because we have removed we have this is
too connected or have purposely bit
disconnect from our own body technology
in a technology in terms of powers we
have you can manipulate reality and and
you know move up you know like through
states of consciousness we cannot even
possibly imagine right now so we're more
more dependent of all the technology and
if you see it how the world the culture
of the matrix works it makes it even
more dependent of it all to remove to
get us out of body even more until we
merge with machine and that's the other
topic so maybe we'll get there but I go
back to what her phrase and summarize
this so the dependency on the embodiment
and this complex beautiful intricate
sold that we have right here in every
single one of us to have then put this
to the side for all of the gadgets and
the technology for the rockets and the
computers and all of the stuff and the
dependency now on those technologies
interestingly enough is potentially
disconnecting us further from our
embodiment very important but but also
simultaneously yes maybe maybe thousands
tens of thousands even more years ago
there were a higher level of embodiment
and therefore then doing things like
astral projection and all these kinds of
amazing entry points into places that
are not the three-dimensional
people's ability to tune into that with
all these lost civilizations that could
have been more advanced Venice but as we
progress further it's looking like it's
super-important for the embodiment which
can also be kind of talked about as
femininity I'm talking about
vulnerability and emotion and feeling
which we're really excited to be doing
our next show Justine musk who's gonna
we're gonna definitely unpack that in so
much detail super different from this
intellectual rockets and computers and
the blending those two together do you
not think is then the ideal no that's
the actually agenda of the ultimate what
I call the end game of the hyper
dimensional matrix is to blend the
embody you know what the technology in
order to fully extract the soul from the
body and for these forces to build our
bodies for international opportunities
to income it fully sorry say that again
one more time to use to you know basic
design or a body's in a sense to
completely disconnect us from our
essence from our soul extract the soul
and build our bodies as incarnational
opportunities for them to income it
because they cannot exist in the 3d
reality right what does it mean that's
that's all if you want to point you to
establish what is the hyper dimensional
matrix let's do this let's do that I
really like how you went with the
embodiment and the technology now let's
explain the hyper dimensional matrix and
then let's also talk about where this
sort of we can also mention this also
ties into UFO this also ties into that
basically which we've mentioned so many
times on the show not only by asking our
guests the question are we alone in the
cosmos but also by the posts that we
made about we are not at the top of the
cosmic food chain we are probably not we
are very likely not at the
top of the cosmic food chain so what
does all of that mean what is the hyper
dimensional matrix control system that
what in a nutshell hyperdimensional
means non-physical right meaning
existing outside our five sensory
perception and we know even though I
said it's very limited of dimensions we
cannot know density we cannot tune into
so there are a lot happening we just
simply another way of right so that
hyper dimensional means non-physical so
matrix what is the matrix right
obviously it relates to the film the
matrix which by the way is an excellent
amazing film in terms of deep esoteric
analogies could be one of the best films
of all time
I mean you know our fifth on the side
note I don't think even the filmmakers
were aware of what they were you know
what was coming through basic yeah yeah
but the way I structured you know and
then people again I can go to my website
obviously for much deeper linking why
are you Valarie audio and videos and
resources but I kind of divided in just
simplify it so to speak in three levels
that's a physical matrix as I see it the
physical control system the obvious for
the motes already start questioning how
we be being controlled and condition and
program by our government institutions
corporations the banking system right or
religion academia media and all of that
education you know our minds are being
formed were literally being programmed
you know on the very basics for example
a basic matrix program a lot of people
don't question is identify and
edification with the country or nation
boom or you know so it's already like
you're identifying with a complete
abstract concept that has no basis in
nature right and that already creates
separation of fragmentation money is
very similar money yeah money itself
like but you know money that sells
that's a whole topic is own wealthy
people funny mistaking abundance of
money or taking the material ryan
intelligence more exactly so that's kind
of like the most people make where
people are aware of right that level
of the matrix well then you can go a
little deeper which I call the deeper
level of the 3d matrix which let me go
into like the shadow government we've
gone to the Rothschilds the bulla Burra
right or the implement what people call
the Illuminati in all of the Zionists
and black government projects secret
space program chemtrails or
geoengineering you know all of that you
know many people are not aware of that
but on the ground level that these are
still just symptoms own expressions
manifestations of the hyper dimensional
matrix the non-physical which is basing
on the root right hit I like the analogy
of the tree like the order matrix right
on the on the trees and the branches and
the hyper dimensional matrix on hidden
in the ground in the root so looking
down from the leaves you can't see the
room so to speak yeah and what is what
what forces are behind that well if you
really study various Oteri teachings
throughout the ages and the onwards
talked about this force that has control
over humanity and he uses humans as a as
an energy source food source so to speak
and any culture and just attach agent
this is understandable similar to how
humans also use other animals and play
us as our food source life feeds on life
and as above so below but on that ROM
food is nothing physical but
consciousness is food and these and
beings forces which have been named
different names different labels so the
ages different teachings but they
literally talk about the same beat from
the Gnostics the archons for example
right the jinn from the Sufism its
addition that a little bit for us the
archons are cornea I'm just naming
likely different you know how these
forces were named right and who made the
naming and what is mean you know Archon
drag is also like relates to ruler like
rulers so to speak you know
and in Sri Aurobindo is like even an
Indian mystical teachings the integral
yoga the occult forces the called simply
means hidden right well adverse forces
then I'm sure you guys have heard of
Paul levy as book I highly recommend
extra for guests to hear his book
dispelling what Tico where Tico is like
this native from the Native American
spiritual tradition this alien virus
that has overtaken humanity right you
see it actually in esoteric Christianity
you know what before the church
corrupted to teaching they used to turn
into dogmatic religion talking about the
general law right that kind of keeps
humanity in its place this force good
you've talked about that a lot and it
varies others it ties into the UFO
phenomenon as well right because it's
interesting this phenomena also this
hyper dimension matrix adjusts itself to
the zeitgeist or the area or most belief
system of humanity it's it's very
shape-shifting right that's why it can
be so deceptive that's why this whole
you of all topic and alien topic may be
teased it's a whole can of worms in
itself John keel he wrote an excellent
book already like nothing was in the
seventies or eighties operation Trojan
horse which I can highly recommend where
he talked about this UFO phenomena how
manipulative or deceptive it is how it
adjusts you know in in certain ways but
again going back to the to the essence
of it so these forces have manipulated
humanity over a thousand hundred
thousands of years to keep us in this
lower state of egoic consciousness of
lower frequency of separation if the
illusion of separation and survival
right and security thinking basically a
fear frequency right so all and then by
disconnecting us even more from spirit
and from nature right we all we all
experience loneliness in our lives like
it's almost this original abandonment
from source right if you lost and then
through the conditioning
we're being oh you know it results in
this body mind split as I talked before
so we get more into our head so the more
you up in your head
you're disconnected from here from
source you're externally more looking
for answer somebody to tell you what to
do and that results into the savior
program which is a huge part of the
matrix to save your program all right
you see those in the religion which also
these forces have manipulated and
installed the religious Savior program
you see the Saviour program in politics
when waiting for the next puppet you
know in office to save the day so to
speak can you unpack that a little bit
because I don't subscribe to you know
democracy or voting for a better life
for no that's government in it's in it's
in it's essence election a conic
creation also instilled by this force
but we've a living we've been living
under these systems for so long we don't
question them anymore
it's a massive collective Stockholm
Syndrome of authoritarian follower z--
all right so but going back the whole
agenda behind hyperdimensional matrix is
we're being farmed for our essence for
energy similar like in the film The
Matrix these machines when you know neo
wakes up out of his sleeping state right
pulls out
unplug himself he sees his feeding field
of humans of what these machines grow
humans and feed off of them right well
you can kind of substitute these
machines for this hyper dimensional
physical or called forces and what do
they feed of it's like these lower
vibrational frequencies specially war
which they create through the human
puppets in government in place in
positions of power to create maximum
suffering you know or interpersonal from
interpersonal fighting even the basic
political agenda we see it now in the US
you know the fact that you know with
Trump Trump puppet in an office it
brought up this huge shadow of the of
the Liberals Democrats progressive who
just project all the hate and anger and
disgust on the guy and they're fighting
each other you know
sense left versus the right creates all
the emotional lose for these forces to
feed upon they couldn't care less who's
and power as long as they can create
this frequency so that on the ground the
root of the issue is this did this this
hyper dimensional force and it works
through these institutions and most of
us people even well-meaning people I'm
not denying their intentions focus on
mistake symptoms for causes right or as
in Plato's famous allegory of the cave
they're just fighting shadows on the
wall or like with the tree analogies
like cutting the trees and the branches
of the tree but they will grow back
anyway in another form and in the
political arena it's like on top levels
a left and a right identical it doesn't
[ __ ] matter right and even that on
the outer level the president even Trump
is not really in charge to begin with I
mean it is a circus three-ring circus
sideshow is there any hope for a local
politics community politics voting fur
you know you did the town selectman or
we have a mail rest race coming up here
yeah but it's like you're still like
it's like you got to go deeper than that
because we have to ask ourselves
fundamental questions right and more
than anything tried to fix it out there
what's going on within you write our own
conditioning write our own program our
own wounds right and I found I have to
drop Swamy Ananda's quote inner
management is the key to unlock your
infinite human potential exactly and
then you align yourself more and more
like if I talked before your inner
potential your soul permanently truly
here to do to contribute to help raise
yeah
the level of consciousness that's good
for those that understand it and
practiced it but we're also looking at
people that want to be led want to be
told where what Bernard was saying
earlier he was saying when the
disconnect occurs from the embodiment
and heads poking around and going where
do I get my source of information from
who do I follow right now is it the
government is it these figures is it
politicians
where am I where am I looking who am i
finding how can I get but it's always
right in here and it's always been right
in here and only when we can figure it
out from inside do we then like you said
the veil that is put right here in front
of our eyes that's covering that up do
we pierce through that and then we get
to understanding the nature the nature
of things as they are and not as the way
that government money borders
nationalism all these things have made
it seem to be right and that it's also
the key actually to conscious true
reality creation which the New Age has
completely distorted right I mean that's
a whole other the New Age religion and a
lot of spiritual teaching how they have
also become distorted right there's a
lot of you know just as we need to
question the mainstream you to ask the
question a lot of spiritual teachings
and New Age and even alternative stuff
out there it's it's it's a big swamp
it's like it's like a maze right but
going back to what you said it's about
then in essentially not fighting the
matrix but transcending it through a
higher level it's all about frequency
right and transcending mean doesn't mean
escaping it either it's kind of ties
into the esoteric saying to be in this
world but not off this world right so
you have you really build this how it
isn't called an esoteric science the
magnetic center within right the
zero-point nonreactive consciousness
you're just fully integrated embodied
which embodiment actually in soul
individualization it it doesn't
necessarily just be into you in your
body right it's an action esoteric
process of growing your soul and and
establish this conscious link and we
have to then nothing on the outside can
affect you can trigger you can throw you
off your sovereign right and then you
continue to respond instead of react
most people react most of us we react
and be mechanically wrecked under the
illusion of free will right or as good
if talk the mass is so mechanical they
you know they live they
to be awake but they're still asleep and
when you engage in this deeper salford
by what means self-focused starts with
basic self observation meditation to
really be able to create this external
witness external witness to observe
yourself your feelings your action you
realize how complicated you are right
how you have all kinds of contradictory
wants needs desires and your ears
they're not even your own they've been
conditioned from the outside and then at
some point you come face-to-face with
what good ship called the horror of the
situation which is not only the external
craziness in forces acting upon us but
our own sleepness state and your own
mechanical behavior and it's so
mechanical that sometimes at the
beginning you may be aware of it but
you're still like doing it anyway so
it's it's it's in quite an intense
process right and but the way I related
in a metaphysical way when you've really
worked through it through your wounding
conditioning and and and seek truth
within and without and establish that
that that the rank letting that
connection to your true soul your true
being
that has tremendous effects on outer
reality right that's how reality is
being created that's because the end the
out is in the end just of reflection of
the inner itself right the reason why
the outside is at the mesh because
people are such the mesh inside in many
ways but the reality creation aspect is
not like the New Age tries to tell me of
just thinking of positive thoughts and
smiling everything will be fine and this
positivity it's a trap in itself
I'm not saying to not be positive but
it's like there's a lot of people
engaged in it they just have a deep
shadow on just young in way right it
just keep suppressing surprising it
needs to come up in some other way
so Sharon a shadow work is the name of
the game in itself it's a descend and
ascend at the same time so that's kind
of like how it relates to in the terms
of metaphysically transcending the
matrix rather than trying to fight it
because fighting it as well means that
you feel something something is wrong in
reality there's somebody made it stake
right we need to fix fix fix things some
you know
but who are you to say that something is
wrong with realities like you are you
God you know that's what for me the most
profound experience or realization of
the past years that there's nothing
wrong with reality
doesn't mean that I'm just sitting back
and like whatever in apathy rides that
kind of trap in itself now I need to
play my part in my robot nothing to see
or what shouldn't be here and everything
but it's hard because everything of
lesser used on that everything is
interrelated ironically everything is
one right it's the irony but on deep on
this lower level of 3d their vast
different expressions of the one and we
are also not all the same which is
another ok not all men are created equal
very true that's actually a true
esoteric esoteric law which will
probably trigger a few social justice
warriors and there's a good amount of
backlash that's currently coming to
people that are talking about genetic
disparities between people on the planet
and I think it's things like IQ and
conscientiousness and emotional to
spirituality that being able to touch
into these different things there are
disparities between people in that sense
and everybody does everybody then have
the potential everyone has the potential
but laughter may have the potential but
the cultural fabric impedes that
potential from coming to life you go to
first to understand that and then you
got a rise above it when he says you
know don't fight the matrix I just call
it you know playing the game just play
the game and you know use the good the
bad and the ugly is tools you know make
it make a decision how you want to be
you know if I want to be a dick what's
your problem
yeah but times most of the time but if I
want to be more of a dick you know I can
be but I choose not to be and that's
what people choose the well at least
you're able to consciously choose when
you know some people don't know when
they're yeah that's I don't know what to
do about that
I can't ugalla can do is just avoid them
or you know I know I'm not gonna change
them I learned you know I can't change
how somebody is I can only change how I
react to them and that took me a while
to you know practice that you know
you've heard of growing up and there's
truth in that so let's let's stay there
cuz that was also in relation to what
Barnard said which was that the change
comes from within the reality outside is
right where it's supposed to be and if
everyone Tunes in to themselves and
makes their inner management work and
foster their divinity that transcendence
of the matrix then the world around them
slowly gets better over time but
everybody needs to tune in and make that
inner work along the way so let's
revisit a little bit let's go back a
little bit so we had the these initial
tangibles
okay so hyper dimensional matrix control
system so these tangibles these most
immediate three-dimensional things are
like things like money or things like
the borders that we have around us and
these are things that are not normally
what would happen in nature these are
constructs that we've created or that
have been created through us into the
world by what exists outside of the
three dimension then there's another
layer so that was the three dimensional
one then the the next layer is kind of
the control layer of who the from the
hyper dimensional control matrix is
being the puppeteers
of what is actually going on in the in
this base 3d reality which is then maybe
the rothschilds the bilderbergs
Illuminati's what's been going on with
all these different governmental
programs that have been run in complete
secrecy we don't still have so much
evidence for so many of the things that
where people are asking for and
immediately they're called out for
loonatics conspiracy theorists there
immediately shut down and that's yeah
and that's how it works you tell they're
damaged you know yeah so yeah also you
have to see like a dead not just reminds
yes the way society and cultures set up
right now if you go speak out about
these topics you know your chances of
success and fame whatever people strive
of money it's severely diminished
you know anybody in a position of fame
or like in the position of public let's
take our cake whatever celebrities actor
whoever is out there you know you cannot
even I remember like you know remember
Charlie Sheen actually he was the only
one who's challenged the question 9/11
many years ago that was before he got
crazy got crazy so it's really
interesting like sure what happened to
me in the light of of the matrix because
I just the only like Hollywood act I
know like what do you deeply question
not the official 9/11 story it was even
like writing a letter to Obama and
reinvestigate boom-boom so you know it
was really coherent rational like and
then you later boom you saw what
happened to him
so that's for me he almost I got you
know who's the other one that recently
went into the middle of Hollywood and
was like what is reality anyway in the
middle of his interview oh you mean like
Jim Carrey Jim Carrey yeah yeah like
he's kind of more like this
philosophical but even then it's still
interesting that these puppies little
bubble up sorry but I'm saying quick
point about prudential control system
that I want to address so because I
think this is important to communicate
from from your essence to root the
viewership
okay so after this money after these
borders after these social contracts
constructs we've created after these
governmental organizations and banks and
societies of bilderberg's Rothschilds
etc what exists outside of that tell us
about that essence because it has
something to do a little bit with the
UFO story as well it has to do a little
bit with what is invisible to the human
senses what exists past the
three-dimensional reality what exists
otherwise in the cosmos and beyond what
is that meshing of the of the god and
the religion with the science and the
evolution what exists outside of that
that you've been describing to us that
could be what is really occurring in
that hyper dimensional state that is
feeding off of some fear that is feeding
off of the political gridlock that
exists in our direction that relates
that the ultimate you know modus
operandi of the of this hyperdimensional
forces is dividing conquer that's the
best way to take over a whole race and
that's what's happening with humans has
always just fighting each other
constantly and how because of either
religious beliefs or national
identification in green and money and
power money see that's also the you know
that ties us into Psychopaths right
people who are genetically born without
a conscience about 1% about 6 to 8% of
humanity right very similar resources
and these Psychopaths are fully occupied
by these four they have no soul
literally they look human but they're
not human but what I'm saying what we
see from the outer level we always feel
on the political level or cooperation of
it they all just want more power and
money and more for themselves and that's
true on that level but since there was
just puppet of these forces again these
forces are just out for that frequency
that louche that food so in the end it's
not about the money right it's just
another symptom for the grid of this
divide and conquer
agenda to create this friggin dissolute
by pitting human humans against each
other and taking in food from that
essence so that's that whatever created
the through that friction right and now
tell us what is that entity I know it's
difficult to put into words whatever why
don't you go find out find out one
second I'll be right back I don't think
you can define as one thing that's it's
you know it's a high there's a high
strangeness X aspect to it right in
terms of being shapeshifters it cannot
just and you have to understand the mind
cannot fully understand it you know it's
like you can like give concept when we
describe it but you know it's it ties
into what your vendor talked about it's
part of as a Terry go to develop a yogic
consciousness right where you can
perceive these forces directly in a
sense and like we briefly touched upon
before right it's not necessarily that
you perceive them visually I don't I'm
never stated I'm not a clairvoyant right
I know of people who do but it's more
like getting established in sixth sense
cognition where the intellect logic the
five senses cannot go and it's more it's
a knowing I cannot even put into words
right I can I cannot possibly prove it
to you scientifically because science
and then when I was based on the five
senses alright but that it's also like
it it relates to to the tried you know
the way we perceive knowledge
understanding it's not just information
right it depends on your level of being
means level of soul embodiment so little
bit individualization and it relates to
for example what good you've talked
about the tried of knowledge being and
understanding right and it's all
interrelated and people think the more
knowledge you have the more
understanding you have which is not true
because if you knowledge is not matched
up of being with embodiment it just
results in information like intellectual
masturbation but not true understanding
which is wisdom
so it goes hand in hand well we're
talking about that the other day yeah we
were at Harvard yeah yeah give us your
quick bit because I wanna i have another
subject that we haven't mentioned too
much that i think we need a touch on
give us that one more time on knowledge
wisdom intellectual masturbation with
these facts versus the embodiment the
look the soul the soul understanding is
then wisdom yeah
so to speak yeah exactly it's like
embodied knowledge like you apply it's
not just okay wisdom is embodied
knowledge okay grab that i think is good
okay and that was what we were talking
about at harvard to longer conversation
solved right here today but if there is
so much more and not solved but that's
pretty good okay let's let's get into
this so like you said it's extremely
difficult to figure out what it is it
requires a development of a sixth sense
some sort of another another tapping
into the unknown
with something that is already limited
to a human cognition and embodiments
very difficult to do but whatever that
is has some sort of fingers in what is
going on today which we were trying to
discuss earlier which we are discussing
now let's talk about this because we
haven't yet fully unpacked this yet you
started unpacking it i think it's a
really it's one of your videos we need
to talk about this love the fact that we
are all saying love we okay because this
is something that ron has definitely
been helping teach me along our journey
together because I am a very positive
meditative optimistic but also realistic
person and I'm very very infrequently
will call people out for their
negativity or them being like cancerous
or them being malevolent beings or them
it's cedra all these different things
but recently
Ron's helped me realize that like Alan
let let that let that come up every once
in a while to let it come up because you
need to figure out where that line is to
push away and go forth and so I wanna I
want you to expand on this because your
your video
I love reality and in time of transition
love reality in the time of transition
right under your films page on your
website you give a very very good point
int understanding that we cannot just go
around and not call out these things we
can't just go around saying love love
love love love and right now eventually
maybe one day when everybody is
practicing in their management and we
are all transcending then love love love
but for the state of now go ahead I do
not think we are going to get there it's
not how the universe works there is not
gonna be a utopian future if we're all
gonna be love love love we're all gonna
be mindless zombies programmed into that
and that's what I think you should be
I'm fearful of that's not what I really
want but you missed a link that I gave
the link that I gave was that it comes
from embody it comes from the practice
of the inner management and that
transcendence if everyone does focus in
on that then it is possible to maybe get
to a point evil love it ok let's let's
have let's have Bernard explain this
what several things one things he said
everyone yes who's everyone and who are
we what's say it may say let's see what
I mean well it's a human souls humans
okay but what I'm saying is it also like
several things to consider okay love you
know love is probably one of the most
abused words besides God so to speak I
would say I'm like Ron I love you he's
like Alan I love Chinese
exactly you know you talk about I love
my country how can you love in the true
meaning of there's a board an abstract
concept of that's unnatural right I love
the you know that knows a good example
now we all known the lessons of love in
various ways in ironically this whole
time on transition when this whole soul
evolution with everything is about for
me all this are lessons in the end of
the day in the in light of soul
evolution wherever you add and you can
also say the lessons in love right
ultimately the ironies the true soul
state it reserves pure state is love and
joy right but it does not depend on
anything outside at all right so but it
is also not an emotion it's not just
feeling up you know which the New Age
has hijacked right this whole like just
just feel of you just this hard thing
right it's also mistaken for many many
many different things now my personal
you know we all relationships we all
struggling with that love you know and
at the beginning when we fall in love it
nobody says it right should rise in love
but you have all these emotions coming
these feeling these projections oh that
was a good one wage rise into love
that's right that's such a good rise
yeah so but you know we mistake that
actually also is love or even like
chemical you know processes that happen
based on the by a lot by ology or
biological programming to procreate
right and all of that so we must take
many many things for us so much we are
so many and that also procreate between
two people hope you know you see the
divorce rate or when people separate
like what then was it true love but you
know what is it really right and some
most often sometimes love trans and to
hate the opposite then what was it
really what it was a true love so what
is love and we never and then we also
conditioned on the romantic level just
through Hollywood romance films and all
of that for you
on a partnership level but you know what
who really opened my eyes there was
those in the 90s when I came across
Jiddu Krishnamurti writing I mean or
heard of him I call him like I love him
he's a lovin I don't know here's like a
special anarchist he renounced his
position from some order like you know
don't follow me no no you know truth
cannot be organized right no institution
no religion no group no nothing right
it's just you and your own process in
life and connection but he he wrote
truth cannot be organized at all he said
he made this give this great parable on
that non real quick wanna mention him
and when he denounced his leadership
from that order they put him in actually
he gave this the story about a man man
in the devil go on a walk you know and
then they see another man pick up some
truth right and then the guy says to the
dev oh this guy found some truth isn't
isn't it bad for you and Deb responds
don't worry
let him organize it hmm so that's you
know there's also for me in my work but
I don't take anything as a on the
foundation I don't attach to one
teaching I don't join any groups or
movements or any of that I mean I'm not
part of any that I used to and learned
the hard way
can't structuring truth be very
beneficial to organizing and designing
civilization to maximize prosperity
let's go back to the logical I want to
say the Krishnamurti he asked the
question that really like opened there
was just like such a ha moment for me we
can only examine understand love by
pointing out what love is not mmm
right you know is passion love is envy
love it's jealousy love is attachment
love right it's possession love like all
these things we actually special
relations some people when they're
jealous they say this se I'm jealous
that means I'm in love with you so we
have convoluted this whole thing so
badly right and then I realized also for
myself like I'm not here well have
realized full of
I'm not an awakened enlightened or
embodied you know I'm learning my
lessons as they you know like what
sometimes the hard way oh yeah yeah most
often anyway but you know it relates to
go back to their different levels of
love as well one can experience they
going back to one's level of being and
soul embodiment right a lot of people
experience love more on a very visceral
level right of like being just physical
sexual emotional level and okay you know
and it's kind of like this contract so
to speak on what here's something I can
do for you and you do this for me
basically right that kind of love we see
a lot of the majority I feel in in
civilization so to speak on that level
right and they're higher states of love
Rhynie go more into the unconditional
love of being which relates to your
level of being right to the point when
you're truly filled with it and and
embodied with this not feeling of love
but it's you know from an esoteric
perspective actually love is like this
knowledge love is knowledge and as a
Terry Christian and they talk about that
love is knowledge but knowledge is not
what we mistake it for this intellectual
and memorized thing now knowledge is
just goes back to understanding being of
just you see things for what they are
right unconditionally that's that's true
love and so it's operating ads and that
it's a vibration and it's a state of
consciousness right love rather than a
feeling that's right right and again
that vast different levels depending on
because we are all different inside as
well that's why I ask you everyone we
are vastly different that vastly
different levels of consciousness with
seven billion people on this planet in
terms of what level of love they are
actually able to access in able to give
and also to receive so it's hard to give
a generous yeah
generalization of what is that and what
you need to do to get there that's good
I think normally when I think about
seven and a half billion people I
normally I think about the ways that we
can all find ways to work together over
I think about it in that sense but when
you bring it up you bring it up in a way
of the different levels of consciousness
in their ability to love and receive
love give love I mean excuse me many
other things you cannot just teach a
tell another person that they have to
they have the experience my selves part
of the soul lesson so whatever contour
you know that is not under you or
anyone's control
okay thought along this topic how can
you if that is then the truth that it
can just be hey like love each other
that's right
how can one then figure out how to what
are your recommendations over your
learning experiences of figuring out how
to transcend how to embody the soul
within and then play dance with reality
in a way that maximizes collective
flourishing how give us a perspective on
that in terms of my own process to
connect to that connect to that and then
in the reality figure out how that how
you can play with reality to maximize
the collective you know what my process
in terms of accessing is deeper love a
big part of it has been actually
suffering my own suffering to dive deep
into the areas in my being I didn't want
to look at to feel the feelings I've
been running away from yeah all the dark
cheddar in the unconscious yeah right
almost like when you to engage sincerely
emphasis sincerely in the process of
awakening right first thing you realize
the self responsibility you have to take
and radical self honesty and there's you
cannot blame anything or anyone anymore
and that opens up a lot cannot blame
anyone or anything anymore you all me
well me but also in the sense you don't
it like that's kind of the parrot you
don't want to blame yourself either
because the day isn't going
on the guilt and shame spiral yes right
yes so it's it's transcending it all
right but still are thinking that
respond responds the ability you know to
respond you know if deep and then the
more I really were to my own wounds
conditioning past life accumulated
whatever stuff you know which oftentimes
comes out in relationship like people
are mirrors like the shadow comes
through and through projections or
triggers basic Jungian psychology right
all these forces are talked about how
they interfere with us can also only
interfere or who can just where we have
our own blind spots and wounds and
issues and you can even which they
heighten you can use them utilize and
actually as teachers so they are not
evil that sense even evil that's just we
can call or around place its purpose so
to speak in the evolution of
consciousness it has its right to exist
you know as part of the dualities it's
freewill to exist but in my own process
the more was you know that's why you
realize seen any esoteric teachings what
your bender talked about no one can
reach heaven without having walked
through hell haven't meaning also
finding that true that joy and body love
that does you know that the true thing
that doesn't depend on anything else but
you need to dive down into the cave into
the underworld to clear everything out
that obstructs the divine force and to
anchor itself within you and I've
noticed like the paradox right the
higher go the deeper need to fall or the
deep I fall the high I can rise descend
and ascend at the same time yeah and now
I realize you know the way to express
myself I'm deaf you know people
sometimes project all kinds of things
into me when they come across my work
what I post on Facebook because I talk
fair a bit amount about the hyper
dimensional matrix of called forces in
the dark side simply that's also like my
path on up by the way I talk about many
other things also about the positive
divine forces but I deal with a lot of
projections of people specially they
don't on me personally that I engage in
fear-mongering that recently somebody
told me that I must live in fear and
paranoia and depression all the time
because I talk about these things I'm
like couldn't be furthest from the truth
you know with everything I've been
through and you know I've been through a
lot of my own tribulations attacks and
you know initiations and whatnot it has
really helped me to come to a very place
of more genuine love and compassion
empathy comes from me easier and more
like just a tease of everything more
acceptance right not acceptance that in
terms of conformity right but I'm also
like you know true love underlying two
aspect of love is also this compassion
empathy right like when you also don't
feel yourself superior which is a trap
in itself when you started by God but
like all the sheep of the you know I
fell into that we all fall into that
right but then totally before like when
I was in summer you know in downtown
waiting for you guys
and I live out a nature I don't see that
many people anymore so I was like whoa
the energy isn't just people watching
was very fascinating and it was like in
tuning into them feeling them and you
see how the majority like autopilot
there's nobody home right it's just so
mechanically like zombies and I'm like
not from its perspective or like
everybody's just you know they're [ __ ]
up but like they don't know what they're
doing that it's just so make you just
see it for what it is right and with
also that compassion or empathy right of
just like then it is what it is right
without the judgment either right so
that's all for me expressions of love
right of like this the state of being in
consciousness and it shows itself in
everyday situations alright and that's
you know the more we tap into that the
more we radiate that right the more we
affect other people's positively with
our frequency and energy and the true
meaning of the word right when we carry
that embodied frequency that shows
itself for example in my body work or
healing hands on work which some has
quite a profound effect on some of my
clients it's not just because of the
technique it's not because of me
whatever but also more about the
frequency you start to carry within
yourself and can affect people even more
effectively than trying to
convinced people by logic or rational
discourse alone but we all have done
that a lot trying to convince you no
because because of this different levels
of consciousness some people simply
won't get it it's even beyond cognitive
dissonance because they're simply not on
a level of consciousness again there's
no very judgment to understand certain
topics probably one of the most easiest
ways to understand that is when you're
in a conversation with somebody and then
one person if the other person in this
case begins to get up up up up up in
their energy level and and angry if you
retort with that anger in that upper
energy level it's gonna be an endless
pop up up up up but if you stay calm and
lean back a bit and be very gentle with
the energy their energy will drop down
to your energy as well over time and I
think that that that right there can be
a really good way to understand control
you mentioned this earlier the
reactionary versus cognition so the more
that you sort of or you're waiting with
your patients and your cognizing and
you're just absorbing the what's going
on rather than immediately reacting to
it the more you'll find yourself in a
position of I'm in control of what's
going on and you feel better about that
good process it's a very important point
that's what the self work comes in and
as I mentioned for the basic foundation
of self work is self observation to not
react but observe so very important like
you mentioned in discussion most people
then become very mechanical they don't
even listen to each other and imitrex
when somebody talks you know you're like
thinking your mind what you're gonna say
without even taking the person's point
in at all
yeah so when you listen to us they even
to an opposing point you know it's
really important to like stay within and
observe what what's the trigger right
what's triggering me you know the
emotions come up yeah and like in just
observing without reacting to it because
it it shows you a lot about yourself you
can learn a lot about yourself in that
moment and then you can respond correct
so to speak there's jacob Needleman he
is
Girja scholar and teacher and he had
this great exercise with his students he
said like you know like said in general
when you know you get into the debate
like he said somebody's complete
opposing viewpoint before you respond to
that person when he makes summarize his
or her point is this the steel man guy
what's his name yeah yeah can Jacob
Needleman G Kamino man I wonder if
that's the steel man guy there's a
difference between steel Manning and
straw Manning people's arguments okay
and this is exactly what you're bringing
up right now if two people are
disagreeing on something to strawman
them is to take what they said in the
worst possible context and do a really
bad job at summarizing joycie that's an
experience with that I'm generally for
that Kathy Newman air exactly and then
steel Manning you take what somebody
says when they're finished summarize it
in a way that they go wow that was good
I never heard that steel steel man burst
straw man I'm glad now it's here so so
then once you steel man somebody and
they go wow that was a really good
summary then and then only at that point
can you either add something on top of
it and be like yeah this or take it and
say that's wrong because of this right
exactly and that's just because it's um
summarize it doesn't mean that you agree
with it you know so but that's really
important because I expended a lot of my
work especially on Facebook right so I
post certain courts excerpts my own
things with the link and people right
away disagree this this but like I think
the majority never actually reads the
whole article in context right and
people comment on something before they
have an opinion about something before
they have actually made the effort to
understand the context you know of why
it was posted and what it relates to so
to speak and then it's taken out of
context which is the usual fallacy right
taking things out of context and and
results always instrument arguments
constantly Wow
social medias straw man pill everywhere
at alive on social
straw Manning and guess what steel
Manning is best for in person so it is
not it's so here's what happens on
social media on social media if you
invest your time into conversation on
social media at best it's one person two
people maybe ten or a hundred people at
best potentially reading that text that
your or you or I are investing time in
to other people who have millions of
followers might get tens of thousands or
hundreds of thousands of people that
read that text but even then they are
still you're in time investment that
you're putting into that is almost
always better for something that looks
closer to reality which is either the
three the 3d in person or on the aisle
I agree rather than text no no I'm like
I'm so I know my friends my friends you
know I like writing I'm like on the
computer like an Internet use it but I'm
the worst texture like I don't like
texting and chatting even because it
gets me up here and it's and so much is
missing and then people misinterpret
words or project emotions the worse
there wasn't sense so much
miscommunication all the time it's one
on one even Skype is better to see the
person the energy the body language the
eye is so much nonverbal communication
is missing yes all right are you all the
time I totally agree with you I'm really
happy we're bringing this up especially
for what one of the things that we
talked about on the show so much is when
you when you observe this content it's
so important to take what you see here
and get think about it in your own way
get inspired by it and go do something
in the world with it go and talk about
it with other people maybe start a
project with it
but go outside and do something with
this content where our content just for
comes consuming purposes is not enough
it's got to be for inspirational
purposes as well to go and get inspired
to do something as well which is a
crucial pillar of what we're what we're
doing there's got to be there's got to
be something that is on your mind that
we should mention
we come to a close on the episode no I
mean they flowed pretty well so I'm just
like I'm in no mind right now I didn't
have any I think that's excellent Ron do
you have something on your mind that we
should talk about em well I I do because
you know I'm like what are the benefits
when I talk about I want to be a better
person going out than when I came in is
there any benefit to that or should I
just enjoy myself like I'm doing you
know I mean I I don't I don't believe
you know death is the end of it all I
think this you know my conscious is
gonna die that this energy is gonna be
transferred but you know a you know I
think the other side is far more chaotic
than the 3d reality I don't know what my
question is I really don't then let me
let me swing in quick then with this in
addition to what we what we discuss
today we mentioned this a couple times
throughout is the idea of having service
be to yourself or service be to other
people and that brings me a lot of
meaning and fulfillment into my life and
I know it has for so many other people
over the last four years of interfacing
with people that are they care about
science that care about entrepreneurship
they care about trying to make the world
better eradicate suffering in many ways
although suffering eradication does have
to come from within
if something can trigger the person to
see within you want to I want to talk
mention that topic of suffering let's do
it it's just a little little thing
because it was realized that also over
the years and there's a paradox within
the realize I got mentioned before the
main catalyst for what I'm doing now has
been suffering and as also almost like
as a Cherica axiom that people don't
truly start to question the world seek
truth that alone engage in deep as a
tray excel fork until they suffer
so suffering has its purpose and that
sense as well in the light of the
evolution of consciousness and
ironically or paradoxically but also you
engage yourself and to get away from
suffering right to get out of the wheel
of samsara right you know that's a whole
you want to wait until nature you don't
suffer anymore right but at the end
suffering was needed to get you there
it's that paradox that was very
interesting line I read by the mother
from Sri Aurobindo
the tree urban and mothers interval yoga
and one of the student asked her like
why is there suffering what's the role
of suffering and he's she said something
profound she said it really may be a
pause and let's contemplate she said
suffering is the only force energy that
can wake up matter out of its inertia
mmm so you know it has its place that's
suffering you know and that's why I see
I have sometimes say how much longer do
we have to suffer until we wake up you
know people that we run away from our
suffering that's a that's a whole
problem in this world the avoidance of
pain and pursue of pleasure you to run
away from pain like this and then the
addictions and buffering up including
social by social spiritual bypassing you
know to get like or you know getting
hooked on psychedelics and the peak
experience medicine plans or bliss
practices to just create that chemicals
right just always more pleasure pleasure
by the avoidance of pain but the one
defines the other the more pleasure you
pursue the more pain believed and she no
you need to come up and tell them so I'm
not talking about being subtle my
masochistic me you know how to like in
dull you know that's another the dark
side of it so to speak but yeah that's
what good you've talked about the fsz
for conscious suffering and conscious
suffering means to really you know don't
act out of just your impulses
questioning observe them right resisted
so to speak a lot of people suffer
mechanically in a sense and they don't
even know that they're suffering right
and then they say that this ones are
really going for resisting the urges for
certain things fasting
passing X such a good one absolutely
it's all psychologically yeah in the end
right
what are you doing besides saying oh
I've been culturally programmed to eat
all the [ __ ] time so what am I gonna
do not eat for a little bit I like to
fast hear that yeah so but the anomalous
that's the whole thing with suffering
it's really interesting to see more from
that almost objective perspective and
since the role of suffering and what it
entails and follow-up to this ok the
analysis both the intellectual analysis
but the embodiment analysis the whole
soulful analysis of the moment-to-moment
being and when I do suffer what is going
on how can I help myself with this
process and then hopefully help others
with this process so that they can tune
in as well okay I know we were touching
on this earlier when we were sitting
down and I want to hear your thoughts on
it as we come to a close the the notion
of an eating suffering that we need it I
want to challenge that and see what your
thoughts are about the challenge that if
a child is born into a world let's say a
thousand years from now hopefully we can
get there in a thousand years or even a
couple hundred years hopefully we can
get there where there is no suffering on
the planet anymore
just imagine prosperity is looking great
when the child's born into the world do
they need to experience suffering in all
these different states in order for them
to be able to move forward or is it
totally good for an okay for them to be
born without into a world without
suffering first I want to put it called
the need to suffer because like this
suffering aspect has been all said
religion has used it to justify
suffering so I don't want to like it put
it in the context you know what I mean
that that all we need something like
okay any just you know what I mean it's
just like a yeah just a byproduct of
also just duality we live in could it
could we bypass but I'm just sorry yes
you know
so that's you know hypothetically
utopian vision which I'm not usually a
big fan of because it's you know I don't
really consider myself but I wouldn't be
able to answer because it depends on the
soul lesson of the child and Who am I to
judge
another person so lesson I don't know
I'm trying to even understand my own
sure I do see it as a very big potential
I've really clearly I feel like there's
a utopian civilization can you know at
some point but then many other changes
like their physiological changes I feel
like believe we like in between right
now I feel also of this full embodied
galactic cosmic human being the full
activated DNA original genetic blueprint
we don't even have organs anymore no
need to eat physical food what other
changes will occur but right and all of
them you know so all of that we we have
you know even ability to inhabit this
body or not like corrects like well
that's a state of consciousness of being
or existence but you cannot even
possibly I mean it may it may be
imagined but not you know understand a
hundred years ago they would be like
what the is going on today well in a
hundred years from now we'll be like
what the [ __ ] was going on back then
hopefully we'll have gone to a point
where some of these things yeah it goes
beyond I mean like many things come into
I mean especially in this day and age I
feel like it ties into we talk about
death the Incarnation process and all of
that and do we actually always have to
come back here as humans right in this
body and I feel many of us doing this
type excuse-me of transition have
actually consciously chosen out of their
free will to come back here to be the
renegades to be to anchor the frequency
to help in the shift you know with our
mission profile we didn't come here for
vacation right which part of me just
wants of F off to Costa Rica live on the
beach but you know but then I'm like
spirit like no you had work so I humbly
aligned it's been one of those strongest
cognitive struggles that I've ever
experienced emotional struggles is that
yeah f off and go and relax
but why am I here yeah I'm not here to
relax on the beach I'm here to make
impact I'm here to help or serve
that's a service yeah okay on that note
Wow for an argument there holy cow
scratching the surface of piercing the
veil of reality really just we scratched
a bit there's so much more to unpack we
will be very grateful to have you back
from Los Angeles in the near future Wow
my mind is expanded to beautiful places
my body is my feelings are my spirit is
feels great there's so much we didn't
get you but that's what yes what do you
didn't we did an hour and a half yeah
well most hour-and-a-half yeah yeah
thank you guys you'd be sure to plug
that I'm about to yeah I'm about to
holy cow every 100 pieces added to the
air
holy cow what yeah what an amazing trip
that was so much fun
covered so many different topics and we
hope that out of all these topics that
we covered that some of them resonate
with you so comment below with your
thoughts we want to feature you on our
Instagram we want to feature you on our
Twitter on our social media platforms we
want to get this content out to more
people hit the subscribe button join our
family we're gonna join Bernard's family
with veil of reality we're gonna explode
this type of communication across the
planet help join watch watch burn arts
films read his essays all on veil of
reality calm links in the bio join him
join their team join us on patreon we
need your help in sustaining the studio
and helping bring bernard up more and
different guests we'd love to continue
expanding do join us on patreon please
Eddie Cadell our producer for today
thank you very much we greatly
appreciate it thank Eddie you the man
yes Eddie its Eddie calm EDD ie calm go
visit him as well again huge thank you
everyone for tuning in Bernard thank you
so much for joining us up here in San
Francisco it's been a pleasure thanks
for having me thank you very much
all right much love everyone peace out
peace